and he is sticking by that with us now
from London and CBS News contributor
that's Roy Anika she's a royal editor of
the Sunday Times in London and she's
covered Britain's monarchy for more than
a decade now good morning to you Roy
Anika you're the perfect person to have
on this morning the day after the
interview what did you make of Harry's
explanation just now that he's not going
to discuss it and leaving it out of the
book
about the races good morning Gail good
morning
good good morning I have to say I'm very
perplexed by this U-turn and this
explanation here because the best part
of two years that narrative has been
allowed to run and I just have to say I
know the default reaction here has been
to blame the British press for almost
everything but we all remember the
reality that when that those comments
were made in that Oprah interview media
and commentators around the world
interpret it as there was some sort of
issue of racism within the royal family
and let's not forget that it's just a
few weeks ago Harry and Megan attended
the Ripple of Hope Gala in New York and
collected an award that was billed for
their courage in standing up to
structural racism within the royal
family so what Harry is saying now is
very different to the narrative they've
been happy to let Run for the last two
years it's very perplexing
well the narrative that they haven't let
go of is the the complications that they
have the complicated relationship they
have with the British press and I'm
curious about your thoughts about this
throughout the book and many interviews
he says listen the British press and the
royal family the institution if you will
are in cahoots that the two get together
and come up with stories plant stories
that are negative to him and to Megan
what can you speak what can you say
about that does he have a point here
I can only speak from my own experience
of doing this job for 12 years and in 12
years of being a royal correspondent and
Royal editor I have never had someone
from a royal household ring me up in the
office or at home to say let me tell you
this awful detail about a member of the
royal family that is that is not how it
works in terms of how I work it tends to
be me taking stories to the households
for commenting for briefing but that was
going on when Harry was inside the royal
family too I would take stories about
Harry to the royal family his people
would check things with him he would
have a certain thing to say about it and
that would be really back to me that is
my experience I can't speak for the
Tabloid media but in terms of sort of
this broad brush approach to the British
press that is not my experience of how
I've done my job for 12 years and I I'm
pretty experienced in this role now
can you see how maybe they feel this way
though Roya based on their experience
and the
can can you see how maybe this is how
they feel because this seems to be their
reality
I I absolutely do I can see how they
feel that you know they talked about it
a lot I completely understand that there
are some elements of the media that
Harry has a real problem with and he
feels you know extremely antagonized by
them I can see how he feels that they've
made certain bits of his relationship
with his family difficult but I think
what's tricky is you know there's a lot
in the in the Anderson Cooper interview
last night and in the ITV one suggesting
that it is you know his breakdown of the
relationship with his family is almost
completely at the British press's feet
and that you know his father and his
brother have a completely distorted view
of reality because of what they read in
the media I think members of the royal
family can think for themselves I do
completely understand where he's coming
from in terms of feeling very
antagonizing that mem certain bits of
the press he has found very difficult to
deal with
but I think you know you've got to take
a step back and and remember and I think
he's forgotten that a lot of us child
around the world with and reported on
all the great work that he and Megan did
for many years and that seems to have
been wiped out of the picture
Roya in an article for Sunday times you
say Prince William is a punching bag for
Harry now although he may be silent you
believe that he is burning inside tell
us what you have learned about his
reaction to all of this
well I did speak to a few of his very
close friends last week to get an
understanding of how he is feeling and
that quote you know outside he's
handling it okay inside he's burning
he's devastated I think he feels and
some of his friends feel that you know a
lot has gone on in that family it is a
family that's that has its complications
like all families but I think he never
thought Harry would go quite as far as
he has
um and he's in a bind because Harry
knows that William is not going to come
out and address every single allegation
it's just not it's not how William rolls
um but he's hurting they're all family
hurting but so is Harry I thought one of
the most saddest quotes from from last
night's interviews was Harry saying
I don't recognize my family and I don't
think they recognize me it's really sad
and there's a long way to go for
reconciliation
I think it is do you think there will be
a Reconciliation here he makes it clear
that he would like to have a his father
he would like to have his brother do you
think but he also says he wants
accountability do you think this is
likely
um I really hope so I mean that was the
strong message I was getting from
sources close to Harry Before Christmas
you know they wanted to Summit they
wanted an apology they want
accountability the problem is scale that
that is trust how can they you know
there's an issue with the royal family
being able to sit down and talk and
speak and and hope that will stay
private but I know deep down all sides
down the line would like reconciliation
so let's hope let's keep our fingers
crossed they can they can heal their
wounds yes over a decade of covering the
royal family your information is
valuable Roy Anika thank you